do you understand why people believe
that by trying to sell your book
you're potentially selling out your own
country well i don't i don't think that
way at all i think the democrats are
upset that their
political malpractice on impeachment
brought them to failure and so of course
they're looking for others to blame but
it's the way they approach the
impeachment process
i think that pre-ordained the outcome
that donald trump is upset with me
doesn't surprise me at all his reactions
frankly have been childish
and degrading to the presidency one of
the most damning aspects
of your book is that you basically
confirm
that there was a quid pro quo with
ukraine
that's ultimately what got the president
impeached and yet
you stayed quiet you didn't testify in
the impeachment inquiry
critics say that that means you're
complicit
and cowardly now i i reject that
completely look
the house democrats took the impeachment
process
right off a cliff and halfway down they
looked up and said hey come and join us
and i was not about to do that you paint
a picture of him as almost
in or of strong men you know desperate
for meetings with kim jong-un and
vladimir
putin were they playing him for a fool
i think they were i think they could see
through him
i don't think they were overt about it
but
i i think they knew exactly who the mark
was
he would say that the relationship with
those men
he was able to foster in a way no other
leader before him did
right well let's take kim jong-un he got
nothing for it after two years of effort
in fact in just the past few weeks
the north koreans have literally blown
up the liaison offices they constructed
to have
talks with the south koreans the whole
thing
came to nothing but a series of photo
opportunities which with all due respect
i think was entirely predictable was
re-election
often put above national security uh in
my judgment yes
trump doesn't really have a philosophy
or a grand strategy or
even policies that he follows it's all
about donald trump and it
it follows from that in in many respects
he has a very short attention span
not when it comes to his re-election his
attention span there
is infinite what do you think is his
worst crime
when it comes to foreign policy
uh look i think ignorance is the worst
crime i i just don't think that
uh saying that uh i don't need
more facts i can i can sit down as he
has said i can sit down with the
ayatollah harmony
we'll we'll hammer out a nuclear deal in
one day
it's just not true so when i think of
the prospect of him on the other side of
the table from vladimir putin
negotiating a strategic arms treaty
i'm i'm very worried for the united
states you describe donald trump as
stunningly
uninformed and that during one trip he
appeared
unaware that britain was a nuclear power
is he really that clueless i can tell
you in that meeting which was at
checkers
hosted by prime minister may when the
president made that comment
the stiff british upper lips didn't
quiver but their eyes got wide as
saucers
and i was sitting there thinking to
myself what do we say next and i think
prime minister may
changed the subject fairly quickly well
let's talk about
theresa may and donald trump's
relationship with her
you say that he didn't like her
that you felt the feeling was mutual can
you elaborate a bit on that
well i think they come from obviously
very different backgrounds have very
different approaches to politics
my own opinion and i can't prove this
i think he has trouble with women
leaders i think he had trouble with
chancellor merkel of germany these are
not substantive disagreements
these are personality issues but because
of the way trump
looks at relations with other leaders he
cannot
he has enormous difficulty
distinguishing between the personal
relationship he has with the leader of
another country
and the fundamental us relationship with
the other country as a whole
do you think he's sexist you know i i
don't know what the issue is but
but time and again we seem to run into
that difficulty
don't get me wrong he had bad
relationships with plenty of male
leaders too
he says he's a stable genius how would
you describe him well let me let me ask
you this
do you know of anybody else in your
personal acquaintance who would say that
about themselves
no neither do i so that's my answer that
tells you
a lot about what you need to know the
u.s
is currently gripped by coronavirus
racial division is this a country in
decline
no i don't think so at all but i do
think that trump leadership
uh during these two crises has made
things worse
much of our failure to respond
effectively
can be laid at donald trump's feet
donald trump didn't want to hear it he
didn't want to hear bad news about
his buddy xi jinping he didn't want to
hear
the truth about china covering up the
extent of the threat of the coronavirus
most important of all he didn't want to
hear about potential bad
economic news for the united states from
a widespread pandemic which would
endanger
his ticket to reelection